hey everybody it's Charlie did one of
you asked for a Nightwing movie because
we totally just got a Nightwing movie
let's just say that after running this
team for a year
peckish for a little action it's really
great news all around everybody's so
happy about Nightwing getting his own
movie so I'll explain what's going on
with the DC EU their schedule there's
like nineteen plus films so they could
do but a lot of those aren't confirmed
yet they just have to do with the
success of the films that precede them
so like this year is very important for
them Wonder Woman has to do really well
Justice League has to do really well or
it could change all the other movies
that are coming after with the exception
of like Aquaman that's already in
production right now so if you're new to
the channel you have no idea what's
going on I do DC videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything I
even have a dedicated DC day there's
giveaways that I'll explain at the end
of the video too because there's some
special stuff happening but pull out
your fanboy cards so the confirmed news
is that Matt Reeves is going to direct
the Batman movie and they're doing a
live-action Nightwing movie with Dick
Grayson with the director of the Lego
Batman movie so if you haven't seen that
movie I recommend you go check it out
even if it's not your usual thing it's
actually a lot of fun if you're a big
Batman fan but as far as casting goes
when it's going to drop nobody knows a
whole lot about the Nightwing movie they
just announced that they're officially
starting to develop it so they found
their director now they're going to
start looking at actors they're going to
start looking at scripts so it's going
to take them a while to work through
that so don't expect to hear a lot about
that before Comic Con so like I said
nineteen plus films just expect them to
announce like what's coming next when we
get to comic-con because they'll be
rolling into Justice League in Warner
Brothers if it's good at anything it is
amazing at marketing its films so
they're going to bring it to comic-con
this year I know a lot of you were
asking about why they didn't talk about
Batman when they release the news about
the Batman movie so I'll address that
but here's the slate of all the movies
they have coming starting with Wonder
Woman so Wonder Woman coming June 2nd
Justice League coming November 17th
probably Zack Snyder's the last film in
the DC EU I think you know everybody's
wondering if people are leaving like Ben
Affleck wants to leave the only person
that I think that is done in the DC EU
as of Justice League is going to be Zack
Snyder and he might like do some
advising from behind the scenes but he's
not going to be directing the next
Justice League movie after that then
there's Aquaman October 5th 2018 then
the flash movie sometime 2019 because
that probably won't go into production
till way later this year it's going to
take them at least six months to shoot
it and then another six months on top of
that to finish post-production and get
it ready so we're talking about 2019 the
Batman movies the next one after that so
it could crawl in at the end of 2018 but
I'm thinking closer to like early 2019
because they're talking about making a
couple edits to the script taking a
couple more passes at it because Matt
Reeves the new director is also going to
be a producer on the film but it didn't
say anything about him writing the
script so even if they don't change it a
lot Deathstroke still in there still a
big character in the movie they'll still
take a couple passes at it which will
take a couple more weeks and then
they'll probably announce a shooting
date later this year and they'll be like
okay we're going to start casting these
other characters here's what's going on
and because obviously they announced the
Nightwing movie I totally think the Dick
Grayson will get a cameo like they'll
wait till the very end of production
because it'll take them a while to
figure out what is going on with the
Nightwing movie they probably have an
idea but like it took a while to figure
the Batman script out it's going to take
a while to figure the Nightwing script
out so they're not going to need their
Dick Grayson for a while and if it takes
them six months to shoot the Batman that
they could even wait till next year to
cast them but again they might have some
more news about that at Comic Con
Marvel's run into that problem too like
when they were looking for Doctor
Strange they really wanted Benedict
Cumberbatch they really wanted to
announce that Robert Downey jr. was
going to be in both of the Avengers
movies way couple years ago but he
hadn't signed his contract yet so they
couldn't announce it at Comic Con so a
lot of times it just depends on when
people have actually signed their
contracts but either way Batman moving
along as planned the next film after
that is Green Lantern cores that's 2020
release date now like I said army hammer
was one of my picks for nightly but the
thing is is that reportedly Warner
Brothers wants him for the Green Lantern
Corps movie so he would be there Hal
Jordan and he does look a little bit
more like Hal Jordans and he looks like
Dick Grayson so the pics are still wide
open there's a cyborg movie which was
originally set for 2020 but they might
change that they might just make him a
bigger character during the flash movie
and not give him a spinoff
movie depending on how these doesn't
moving through there's a Suicide Squad
sequel which they just announced Mel
Gibson is supposedly going to direct it
but they haven't officially confirmed
that yet
then there's the Gotham City sirens
movie that David airs directing they
don't have a date for that yet they just
said that they're actually working on it
there's a Deadshot movie that they're
supposedly developing for Will Smith no
word on that it just is they're working
on it behind the scenes so it might come
together the Man of Steel 2 movie is
only listed as being in active
development there's no release date it
would probably fall sometime after the
second Justice League movie if it ends
up happening
Nightwing just got announced you guys
know about that the Shazam movie was
announced a little while ago but it
looks like the other movie because
there's - Shazam movies
one of them's going to be a Black Adam
movie and the other one's going to be a
Shazam movie if you referred to Black
Adam as a hero but he's a villain what's
that mean for the movie it's really in
car interpretation and who we deemed
been a hero yes of course black Adams in
the mythology is a villain or he could
be considered an antihero or twosome
he's a hero to some who have a black
heart like me again I love the back
story that he started off as a slave and
he was held doubt and I think when that
kind of backstory about a man is held
down and he rises up out of that to
become greater and then dealing with the
conflict the pain of losing his family
it's dark but it also adds to the
gravity and adds to the weight of the
story so what does it mean for the movie
it means that the movie is going to be
fantastic and it means that it's going
to be badass and it means to me he's a
hero because they have the rock and he
is such a hot star right now the Black
Adam movie is probably going to come
first and then they'll introduce the
Shazam character during that they
announced the Doug Liman Justice League
dark live-action movie the ones at
Guillermo del Toro been trying to get
off the ground for a long time that's
still in development there's a Lobo
movie that's also in development and in
the second Justice League movie which
used to be a Zack Snyder thing but
that's probably not going to go down now
they'll probably announce the new
director sometime in the next couple
years but those are all
movies the DC has in the DC EU release
schedule that it's actively developing
the other big one that everyone's asking
about now is Teen Titans because they
have the dick race and Nightwing if they
want to if everything goes according to
plan
they can totally do Teen Titans it's a
big reality but there's nothing
confirmed they haven't announced
anything about it that sounds like a
comic-con thing like hey you see all
this stuff is going on like if
everything goes well this year they'll
be like look at all these other amazing
movies that we're developing now based
on successful properties so a lot of
that just depends on how successful the
DC EU is this year because bringing it
back around to Ben Affleck Batman
everybody's wondering is he leaving you
know what's up with the rumors so the
thing is is that he is probably going to
stay all the way through Justice League
no matter what happens even if he does
want to leave but there's just a lot of
things pointing towards him staying you
know gut feeling is the eastes through
that second Justice League film assuming
that they actually end up making it now
anything could happen down the road but
the thing is is that Ben Affleck right
now is kind of in movie Jail his last
movie that he directed and started did
not do very well so he needs a big hit
which is the Batman movie it's a
guaranteed hit even if it's just an okay
movie but after justice Lee comes out
and if he does really want to leave
they'll probably wait till after the
Batman movie comes out late 2018 early
2019 so even if he did leave the role as
Batman he will still be Batman for a
couple more years for a couple more
movies remember they love Batman they
put him in all the movies he's in like a
billion different comic books right now
and the reason that they didn't mention
him in that press release is because
it's all about getting credit it's all
about Matt Reeves so the whole reason
that he actually walked from talks
briefly like people were like oh my god
he's bailed he's not going to do the
movie the whole reason for that is
because his agent just asked for a giant
paycheck like 10 15 million dollars in
warner brothers is like whoa you know
pump the brakes on that we're not going
to pay you that much money so his really
good Hollywood agent that represents a
lot of the other DC directors did the
Power Move thing where you use the press
against the studio so director leaves
and it makes
look like the movies in trouble so
Warner Brothers panics and is like okay
let's make a deal so he's not getting as
much money but he has a producer credit
so he's going to get a lot more on the
back end it's all a money thing it's
really just a negotiating tactic so the
movie itself is totally fine don't worry
about it
Nightwing is going to be a lot of fun to
follow through the rest of the year
they'll probably be a bunch more news
about it as we get closer to comic-con
but let me know what do you guys think
about all this I think it's going to be
pretty crazy this year but I think the
nightly news is Batman news is enough to
turn people around like we're even
getting ready for a Justice League
trailer pretty soon it's not going to
come this month but it'll probably be
some time before Wonder Woman hits
theaters so I'm guessing sometime in
April but we'll probably hear more about
that in a little while so what's going
to happen is I will have like a
dedicated DC video day it sounds like
Monday's are going to be Marvel stuff so
I think what's going to happen is it'll
either be Tuesdays because I already do
flash stuff or it'll be like Fridays or
Saturdays so you guys can let me know
which day you want to make DC day
there's a new round of the injustice to
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Batman Nightwing stuff on this
video congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Tony Adams please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details what's going to happen next is
is it Star Wars day tomorrow there's a
whole bunch of Star Wars news but I also
got some Deadpool x-force that's crazy
so I'll be posting that too and there's
that crazy injustice trailer so those
will be the next videos that I post but
I'll update to schedule as I post those
new videos so I'll let you guys know
what's going to be happening this
weekend all the craziness it is going to
be great while you wait for that you can
click here to re-watch that Thor
Ragnarok teaser and you can click here
to learn all about Aquaman thank you so
much for watching
let's iBot i'll see you guys in the next
video
you